vous allez madame lebaye compliqué à
11h25
gisèle l'évêque 89 ans est devenue la
première canadienne vaccinés contre la
corée 19 une résidente du ch et celle
des saint-antoine à québec
très loin derrière à montréal il y avait
gloria la loose du ch et celle des
maronites
je sens très bien
sans toujours au galement heureuse
aucune douleur mais beaucoup d'espoir de
sortir enfin de l'isolément
j'ai rester dans ma chambre ça fait
maintenant huit mois sans sortir la
coved lui a à ses volets de temps et
d'amis
j'ai perdu une personne avec l'arrivée
des quatre mille premières doses du
vaccin au québec c'est le début de la
fin de cette pandémie
c'est une grande journée historique pour
le québec
on devrait être capable de vacciner
jusqu'à plus de 50000 personnes d'ici le
4 janvier pour nous c'est une victoire
c'est la façon de tourner la page à
maemo need 95% des quelques 300
résidents ont accepté de se faire
vacciner dont la mère d'elisabeth klein
un coach est pour aider les aînés le
deuxième côté cdeps cobayes et sa
semaine qui est un peu un peu de
réticence surtout chez les employés
parce qu'après les résidents ce sera
leur tour
environ 500 employés de 35 à 40% qui ont
dit oui faisons hui ferme et en a
d'autres qui ont dit oui mais pas
maintenant on veut atteindre la deuxième
vague parce qu'on veut voir comment les
gens vont réagir supprime aussi une
proportion surprenante mais qui
n'inquiète pas trop d'un vaccin comme
pour la grippe
d'ailleurs rien de dramatique écoutez
cent pensent avoir la colite que tu es
plus 5000 personnes me fais vacciner
avec enthousiasme quand le moment
viendra évidemment il faut donner
priorité aux personnes les plus
vulnérables et plus vulnérables comme
gloria la loose qui a choisi le camp du
vaccin
j'espère que tout le monde reçoit le
vaccin parce que c'est important de
continuer de vivre ici jacques houde
richard dunne ou radio canada
mon frère